T
AIN'T ENOUGH TO GET THE VACCINEW
MILLION
ERRAN R-A IDRSN OWD
E EWHAY
ETEEOMU S RY
DR AOPIN MFE M -H E OT
Y  TJUOLENRKDA
G GOEVG ACEANGRAI'ARATONHEE.AM
Y THEENHASTF ARD GOAYT D ITHAON
Y WAINEN WIFT
LL STC
EE
W  AOF
CATIZD URP. H
SESA
AGTHVE SCO BISFO F IXCEAIN
YSH ITHK YOESDES TH
OLHOJONEOUUPEND ATN HAEAJOAD NG
INDG,
LYG D TOO S R
BEG.--, ATHA TE ISAFMPEIT'FI
T T M W -RE FLEMESE
PEAWT H,>>SE W FTOOUTOHO
Y
LO TAC K, HEFAKI?ETONNG
TOMA TPP  T IA IASSIBEIRGE TPH
OUTTONHTCIINAY-- HPH
NETOMIDSEN RS TEI Y AN BYBHAEN
MAHIH BA
MI YMIDECASTHE
TLEOWT IL
ERO NED
LYSALIGE VDR YTIGI
NGOU-O- NTUSFUR HE FH  R WWEDORS
IDFE BACAW
W
OU
LLFRRO TEAEIIRESDEUR
WAN HW,Y NVTH
O?THTO $ FOM, LLRD UETFEOU
YMYSEONS EY WYOIN YAN INDHISOW
S INBEJO
S N  G TVA W.  GURWS  VER
OU>> TANE E WOE EVSHGOORINEASY
ALWIISLI TY ANCOCHATS I  SA  CR
TVEOLELCIREERLDBUSOND HATVE OVI
H HE TRYLES TEIN RYISC SI